let's zoom in at this very particular
question of
computation
on a processor and communication
between processors
so
what does this
system look like
that you're envisioning
one of the places you're envisioning it
is in the paper on optoelectronic
intelligence
so what are we talking about are we
talking about something that starts to
look a lot like the human brain or does
it still look a lot like a computer what
are the size of this thing is it go
inside a smartphone or as you said does
it go inside something that's more like
a house
like uh
what should we be imagining what are you
thinking about when you're thinking
about these fundamental systems
let me introduce the word neuromorphic
there's this concept of neuromorphic
computing where what that broadly refers
to is
computing based on the information
processing principles of the brain
and as
digital computing
seems to be pushing towards some
fundamental performance limits
people are considering architectural
advances drawing inspiration from the
brain more distributed parallel network
kind of architectures and stuff and so
there's this continuum of neuromorphic
from
things that are
pretty similar to digital computers but
maybe there are more cores and the way
they send messages is a little bit more
like the way brain
neurons send spikes but for the most
part it's still digital electronics
and then you know you have some things
in between where maybe you're you're
using
transistors but now you're starting to
use them instead of in a digital way in
an analog way and so you're trying to
get those circuits to behave more like
neurons and then that's a little bit
quite quite a bit more on the
neuromorphic side of things you're
trying to get your circuits although
they're still based on silicon you're
trying to get them to
perform operations that are highly
analogous to the operations in the brain
that's where a great deal of work is in
neuromorphic computing people like
yakimo and davari and gert kaunbergs
jennifer hasler countless others it's
it's a rich and exciting field
uh going back to carver mead in the
late 1980s and then all the way on the
other extreme of the continuum
is where you say i'll give up
anything related to transistors or
semiconductors or anything like that i'm
not not starting with the assumption
that i'm going to use any kind of
conventional computing hardware and
instead what i want to do is try and
understand what makes the brain powerful
at the kind of information processing it
does and i want to think from first
principles about
what hardware
is best going to enable us to
capture those information processing
principles in an artificial system
and that's where i live that's where
that's where i'm
doing my exploration these days so uh
what are the first principles
of
brain like
computation communication right yeah
this is this is so important and i'm
glad we booked 14 hours for this because
uh i only have 13 i'm sorry
okay so the brain is notoriously
complicated and i think that's a
an important part of why it
why it can do what it does but okay let
me let me try to break it down starting
with the devices
neurons as i as i said before they're
they're sophisticated devices in and of
themselves and synapses are too they
they can um
change their state based on the activity
so they they adapt over time that's
crucial to the way the brain works they
don't just adapt on one time scale they
can adapt on
myriad time scales from
the the spacing between pulses the
spacing between spikes that come from
neurons all the way to the age of the
organism
um
also relevant perhaps
i think the most important thing that's
guided my thinking is the the network
structure
of the brain so which can also be
adjusted yes on different scales
absolutely yes so so you're you're
making new con you're changing the
strength of contacts you're changing the
the spatial distribution of them all
those spatial distribution doesn't
change that much once you're a mature
organism but that network structure is
is really crucial
so let me dwell on that for a second
um
you can't talk about the brain without
emphasizing that most of the neurons in
the the neocortex or the prefrontal
cortex the part of the brain that we
think is most responsible for
high-level reasoning and things like
that those neurons make thousands of
connections so you have this network
that is highly interconnected
and
i think it's safe to say that one of the
primary reasons that they make so many
different connections is that allows
information to be communicated very
rapidly from any spot in the network to
any other spot in the network so that's
a that's a sort of spatial aspect of it
you can quantify this
in terms of
concepts that are related to fractals
and scale invariants which i think is is
a very beautiful concept so
what i mean by that is kind of no matter
what spatial scale you're looking at in
the brain
within certain bounds you see the same
general statistical patterns so if i
draw a box around some region of my
cortex
most of the connections
that those neurons within that box make
are going to be within the box to each
other in their local neighborhood and
that's sort of called clustering loosely
speaking but a non-negligible fraction
is going to go outside of that box and
then if i draw a bigger box the pattern
is going to be exactly the same
so you have the scale and variance and
you also have a non-vanishing
probability of a neuron making
connection very far away so
suppose you you want to plot the
probability of a neuron making a
connection as a function of distance if
that were an exponential function it
would go e to the minus
radius over some characteristic radius
and it would it would drop off
up to some certain radius the
probability would be
reasonable close to one and then a
beyond that characteristic length r zero
it would it would drop off sharply and
so that would mean that the neurons in
your brain are really
localized and
that's not what we observe instead what
you see is that the probability of
making a longer distance connection it
does drop off but it drops off as a
power law so the probability that you're
going to have a connection at some
radius r goes as r to the minus some
power and that's more that's what we see
with with forces in nature like the
electromagnetic force between two
particles or gravity goes as one over
the radius squared so you can see this
in fractals i love that there's a like a
fractal dynamics of the brain
that
if you zoom out you draw the box and you
increase that box by certain step sizes
you're going to see the same statistics
i think that's probably
very important to the way the brain
processes information it's not just in
the spatial domain it's also in the
temporal domain and what i mean by that
is
that's incredible that this emerged
through the evolutionary process that
potentially somehow
connected to the way the physics of the
universe works yeah i i couldn't agree
more that it's a deep and fascinating
subject that i i hope to be able to
spend my life studying you think you
need to solve understand this this
fractal nature in order to understand
intelligence and company i do think so i
think they're deeply intertwined yes i
think power laws are right at the heart
of it so just to just to push that one
through the same thing happens in the
temporal domain so suppose you had
um
suppose your neurons in your brain were
always oscillating at the same frequency
then the probability of finding a neuron
oscillating as a function of frequency
would be this narrowly peaked function
around that certain characteristic
frequency that's not at all what we see
the probability of finding neurons
oscillating or
pulsing producing spikes at a certain
frequency is again a power law which
means there's no
there's no defined scale of the temporal
activity in the brain
it's you don't what at what
speed do your thoughts occur well
there's a there's a fastest speed they
can occur and that is limited by
communication and other other things but
there's not a characteristic scale we
have thoughts on all temporal scales
from you know a few
tens of milliseconds which is
physiologically limited by our devices
compare that to
tens of picoseconds that i talked about
in superconductors all the way up to the
lifetime of the organism you can still
think about things that happened to you
when you were a kid or if you want to be
really trippy then across multiple
organisms in the entirety of human
civilization you have thoughts that span
organisms right yes taking it to that
level if you're willing to see the
entirety of the human species as a
single organism with the collective
intelligence and that too on a spatial
and temporal scale
there's thoughts occurring and then if
you look at not just the human species
but the entirety of life on earth
as as an organism with thoughts that
occurring that are greater and greater
sophisticated thoughts there's a
different spatial and temporal scale
there
this is getting very suspicious
hold on though before we're done i just
want to just tie the bow yes and say
that the
the spatial and temporal aspects are
intimately interrelated with each other
so activity between neurons that are
very close to each other is more likely
to happen on this this faster time scale
and information is going to propagate
and encompass more of the brain more of
your cortices different modules in the
brain are going to be engaged in
information processing on longer time
scales so there's this concept of
information integration where
most neurons are neurons are specialized
any given neuron or any cluster of
neuron has its specific purpose but
they're also um they're also
very much integrated so you you have
neurons that specialize but share their
information and so that happens through
these fractal nested oscillations that
occur across spatial and temporal scales
i think capturing those dynamics in in
hardware
to me that's the goal of of neuromorphic
computing so does it need to look so
first of all that's fascinating we
stated some clear principles here
now does it have to
look like the brain outside of those
principles as well like what other
characteristics have to look like the
human brain or can it be something very
different well it depends on what you're
trying to use it for and so i i think a
lot of the community
asks that question a lot what are you
going to do with it and
i i completely get it i think that's a
very important question and it's also
sometimes not the most helpful question
what if what you want to do with it is
study it what if you just want to see
um
what does it what do you have to build
into your hardware in order to observe
these dynamical principles
so
and also
i ask sometimes i ask myself that
question every day and i'm not sure i'm
able to answer that it's like what are
you what are you gonna do with this
particular neuromorphic machine so
suppose what we're trying to do with it
is build something that thinks we're not
trying to get it to make us any money or
drive a car maybe we'll be able to do
that but that's not our goal our goal is
to
see if we can get the same types of
behaviors that we observe in our own
brain and by behaviors in this sense
what i mean
the behaviors of the components the
neurons the network that kind of stuff i
think there's another element that i
didn't really hit on that that you also
have to build into this and those are
architectural principles they have to do
with the the hierarchical modular
construction of the network and without
getting too lost in jargon
the the main point that i think is
relevant there let me try and illustrate
it with a cartoon picture of
the architecture of the brain so in the
brain you have the
the cortex which is sort of this outer
sheet um it's actually a you can it's a
layered structure you can if you could
take it out of your brain you could
unroll it on the table and it would be
about the size of a of a pizza sitting
there
and um
that's a module it it does certain
things it it processes as yorgi buzaki
would say it processes the what of of
what's going on around you but you have
another really crucial module that's
called the hippocampus
and that that network is structured
entirely differently first of all this
this cortex that had described 10
billion neurons in there so numbers
matter here
and they're they're organized in that
sort of power law distribution where the
probability of making a connection drops
off as a power law in space the
hippocampus is another module that's
important for
understanding how
where you are
when you are um
keeping track of of your your position
in space and time and that network is
very much random so the probability of
making a connection
it it almost doesn't even drop off as a
function of distance it's the same
probability that you'll make it here to
over there but there are only about 100
million neurons there so you can have
that huge densely connected module
because
it's not so big
and the the neocortex or the cortex and
the hippocampus they talk to each other
constantly and that communication is
largely facilitated by what's called the
thalamus i'm not a neuroscientist here
i'm trying to do my best to recite this
cartoon picture of the brain i gotcha
yeah something like that so this
thalamus is is coordinating the activity
between the neocortex and the
hippocampus and making sure that they
they talk to each other at the right
time and send messages that will be
useful to one another so this all taken
together is called the thalamocortical
complex
and it seems like building something
like that is going to be crucial to
capturing the
types of activity we're looking for
because
though those responsibilities those
separate modules they do different
things that's got to be central to
achieving these
states of efficient information
integration across space and time
by the way
i am able to achieve this state by
watching
simulations visualizations of the thelma
cortical complex there's a few people i
forget from where they've created these
incredible visual
illustrations of like
visual stimulation from the eye or
something like that it this in this
image like flowing through the brain wow
i haven't seen that i got to check that
out so it's one of those things you you
find this stuff in the world
and you see like on youtube it has like
1000 views these like
these visualizations of the human brain
processing information and like
because there's uh there's chemistry
there like because this is act from
actual human brains i don't know how
they're doing the coloring but they're
able to actually trace
the uh like different the the chemical
and the electrical signals throughout
the brain and the visual thing it's like
whoa because it looks kind of like the
universe i mean the whole thing is just
incred i recommend it highly i'll
probably post a link to it but you can
just look for uh
um
one of the things they simulate is the
uh
thelma cortical uh complex and just
visualization you can find that yourself
on youtube but it's it's beautiful um
the other question i have for you is um
how does memory play into all this
because all the signals sending back and
forth that's kind of like uh that's
computation
and communication but that's kind of
like
uh you know processing of
inputs and outputs
to produce outputs in the system that's
kind of like maybe reasoning maybe
there's some kind of recurrence but like
is there a storage mechanism that you
think about in the context of
neuromorphic computing yeah absolutely
so that's got to be central you have to
have a way that you can
store memories and
there are a lot of different kinds of
memory in the brain that's
yet another example of how it's not a
simple system so
there's one kind of memory one way of
talking about memory
uh usually starts in the context of
hopfield networks you were lucky to talk
to john hopfield on this program but the
the basic idea there is uh working
memory is stored in the dynamical
patterns of activity between neurons and
you can you can think of a certain
pattern of activity as an attractor
meaning if you put in
some
signal that's similar enough to other
previously experienced signals
like that then you're going to converge
to the same network dynamics and you
will see
these neurons
participate in the same network patterns
of activity that they have in the past
so you can talk about the probability
that
different inputs will allow you to
converge to different basins of
attraction and you might think of that
as oh i saw this face and then i excited
this network pattern of activity because
last time i saw that face i was at you
know what some movie and that that's a
famous person on the screen or something
like that so so that's one memory
storage mechanism but crucial to
the ability to imprint those memories in
your brain
is the ability to change the
strength of connection between
one neuron and another that synaptic
connection between them so synaptic
weight update is a massive field of
neuroscience and neuromorphic computing
as well so
there are
two
poles to that
on that spectrum one in okay so in more
in the language of machine learning we
would talk about supervised and
unsupervised learning
in when i'm trying to tie that down to
neuromorphic computing i will use a
definition of supervised learning which
basically means
the external
user the person who's controlling this
hardware has some knob that they can
tune to change each of the synaptic
weights depending on whether or not the
network's doing what you want it to do
whereas what i mean in this conversation
when i say unsupervised learning is that
those synaptic weights are are
dynamically changing in your network
based on nothing that the user is doing
nothing that there's no wire from the
outside going into any of those synapses
the network itself is reconfiguring
those synaptic weights based on physical
properties that you've built into the
devices so if if the synapse receives a
pulse from here
and that causes the neuron to spike
some circuit built in there with no help
from me or anybody else adjust the
weight in a way that makes it more
likely to
store the useful information and excite
the useful network patterns and makes it
less likely that random noise useless
communication events will have an
important
uh effect on the network activity so
there's memory encoded in the weights uh
the synaptic weights what about the
formation of something that's not often
done in machine learning the formation
of new synaptic connections right well
that seems to so again not not a
neuroscientist here but my reading of
the literature is that that's
particularly crucial in early stages of
brain development where a newborn is uh
born with tons of extra synaptic
connections and it's actually pruned
over time so the number of synapses
decreases as opposed to growing new
long-distance connections it is possible
in the brain to grow new neurons and um
assign new synaptic connections
but it doesn't seem to be the primary
mechanism by which
the brain is learning so for example
like right now
sitting here talking to you you say lots
of interesting things and i learn what i
learn from you and i can remember things
that you just said and i didn't grow new
axonal connections down to new synapses
to to enable those it's
plasticity mechanisms in the between the
synaptic connections between neurons
that enable me to
learn on that time scale so at the very
least that you can sufficiently
approximate that with just weight
updates you don't need to form new
connections i would say weight updates
are a big part of it i also think
there's more because
broadly speaking when we're doing
machine learning our networks say we're
talking about feed forward deep neural
networks
the temporal domain is not really part
of it okay you're going to put in an
image and you're going to get out of
classification and you're going to do
that as fast as possible so you care
about time but time is not part of the
essence of this thing really
whereas in spiking neural networks what
we see in the brain
time is as crucial as space and they're
intimately intertwined as i've tried to
say
and so adaptation on
on different time scales is important
not not just in memory for formation
although it plays a key role there but
also in just keeping the activity in a
useful dynamic range so you have other
plasticity mechanisms not just weight
update or at least not on the
time scale of many action potentials but
even on the shorter time scale so a
synapse can
become much less efficacious it can it
can transmit a weaker signal after the
second third fourth that can
uh second third fourth action potential
to occur in a sequence so that's what's
called short-term synaptic plasticity
which is a form of learning you're
learning that i'm getting too much
stimulus from looking at something
bright right now so i need to tone that
down you know
um there's also another really important
mechanism in learning it's called
metaplasticity what that seems to be is
a
a way that you change not the weights
themselves but the rate at which the
weights change so
when i am in
say a lecture hall and my
this is a
potentially terrible cartoon example but
let's say i'm in a lecture hall and uh
it's time to learn right so my brain
will release more perhaps dopamine or
some
neuromodulator that's going to change
the rate at which synaptic plasticity
occurs so that can make me more
sensitive to learning at certain times
more sensitive to overwriting previous
information and less sensitive at other
times and finally as long as i'm
rattling off the list i think another
concept that falls in the category of
learning or memory adaptation is
homeostasis or homeostatic adaptation
where
neurons have the ability to
control their firing rate so if if one
neuron is just like blasting way too
much it will naturally tone itself down
it's its threshold will adjust
so that it's it stays in a useful
dynamical range and we see that that's
that's captured in in deep neural
networks where you don't just change the
synaptic weights but you can also move
the thresholds of
of simple neurons in those models and so
to uh
to achieve
this
spiking neural networks
you want to use
like
you want to implement
the first principles that you mentioned
of the temporal and the spatial
fractal dynamics here so you can you can
communicate locally you can communicate
across much greater distances and do the
same thing
in space and do the same thing in time
you